la lettre que bernard cazeneuve a
adressé hier à tous les policiers n'a
pas suffi à calmer leur colère
il ya un zéro pointé pratiquement sur
toute la ligne sur la façon dont le
gouvernement gère cette crise là et plus
largement de président de la république
se comporte depuis un certain nombre de
mois maintenant par ce qui me choque ce
sont les attaques que subissent les
policiers et les gendarmes avec une
violence qu'on avait jamais connu
jusqu'à présent puisqu'il ya même des
tentatives d'homicide contre les forces
de l'ordre
il faut redonner du tonus aux
socialistes leur redonner du moral delà
de la fierté défendent ce que nous avons
engagées c'est à dire le bilan même si
évidemment il ya des réussites et
également des échecs rien ceux qui
considèrent le premier comme un
collaborateur ceux qui considèrent le
premier comme un concurrent ce qui n'est
pas un moindre projet vu par exemple
mais par exemple vous voyez bien triste
demande arnaud à benoît
aurélie emmanuel patois l'autre qu'est
ce qui nous sépare parce qu'on appelle
au rassemblement il devrait nous amener
à revoir aujourd'hui ce que sont nos
échecs sortir de ce déni le quinquennat
de françois hollande est pour partie
l'accélération que lui a donnée eux
manuel valls est largement aujourd'hui
responsable de la situation dans
laquelle se trouvent les français
nous devons donc réagir réagir vite
réagir pour cesser de subir réagir
maintenant pour ne pas mourir demain car
est ce que françois hollande est sorti
du coma
je crois qu'il n'y ait pas entrer a donc
il est resté ce qu'il était normal
les livres sur françois hollande se sont
dangereusement accumuler le dernier un
ouvrage de confidences à deux
journalistes fait même vaciller le chef
de l'état certains proches de françois
hollande glisse mais en partant du livre
en par toi plutôt que le critiquer comme
celle fait c'est le cas actuellement pas
parmi certains des proches en patois de
ce livre parce que c'est à vis ton
fessier selon eux enfin le racing un
canal à la présidentielle vous imaginez
que vous allez affronter qui françois
hollande ou manuel valls ségolène royal
fou emmanuel macron le candidat que la
gauche choisit pourquoi pas vous non non
parce que j'ai pas ce que j'ai déjà
beaucoup donné
le moment n'est pas venu d'aborder la
question de l'échéance présidentielle
mais vous entendez ce qui se passe chez
les socialistes cette semaine c'est
terrible non mais que les questions
soient les soit légitime ça je n'en
disconviens pas elle a fermé la porte
n'a pas fermé
elle priverait rêve aurait été d'être
élue députée européenne en 2009 avec
dany cohn-bendit et de le voir dans
l'hémicycle c'était ça quand j'avais
remis au boulot de merde eh bien je
considère que en politique c'est un peu
sa vie
s'ils voulaient vraiment faire le boulot